Republicans face growing pressure to
call witnesses in the president's
impeachment trial after reports of
explosive allegations from former
national security adviser john bolton in
his upcoming book some in the GOP who
had expressed their openness to calling
witnesses are now doubling down on that
view while others still appear to be
very unmoved Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with more on this story Nancy
realistically what are the chances you
think that john bolton will in fact
testify well Gail if you just look at
the math we're now just one senator away
from having the votes that Democrats
need in order to bring Bolton in to
testify they've got three Republicans
they're looking for one more this Bolton
firestorm ignited a huge controversy
here on Capitol Hill right in the middle
of the trial but it went largely
unnoticed and Barista the president's
legal team focused its defense yesterday
on presidential candidate Joe Biden
after Vice President Biden was made US
point man for Ukraine his son Hunter
Biden ends up on the board of Purisima
it wasn't until the final hour of
arguments that John Bolton's name even
came up nothing in the Bolton
revelations even if true would rise to
the level of an abuse of power or an
impeachable offense according to the New
York Times Bolton in his upcoming book
says that President Trump directly
conditioned military aid to Ukraine on
an investigation into the Biden's
and while some Republicans shrugged that
revelation off I think it's going to
vindicate the president Democrats say
the information Bolton has is more
crucial than ever
first-hand knowledge
mandates that we hear from them and they
just need for Republicans to side with
them three Republicans have already said
they're open to it including Utah
senator Mitt Romney I think it said
increasingly likely that other
Republicans will will join those of us
who think we should hear from John
Bolton on Monday President Trump denied
Bolton's claims I can tell you nothing
was ever said - and some of his
defenders warned that a vote against the
president could be costly do you think
Republican senators face political
repercussions if they break with the
president yeah I do I mean listen I
don't want to speak for my Senate
colleagues but but there are always
political repercussions for every vote
you you take there is no vote that is
higher profile than this sources tell us
some Senate Republicans are angry that
the White House had this Bolton
manuscript for weeks and never said
anything about it to them even leader
Mitch McConnell himself was blindsided
one Senate Republican Pat Toomey of
Pennsylvania is now trying to pitch his
GOP colleagues on a one-for-one swap
where Republicans would get a witness
they want to hear from in exchange for
Democrats getting one of theirs
ostensibly Bolton Anthony very
interesting Nancy thank you a Nancy
Cordes on Capitol Hill